With buoyancy and waves now completed, that's going to bring us to the end of this video tutorial series.
So we first started this video tutorial by showing you how to enable the water plugin.
Remember, once you've enabled it, you do need to restart the editor.
We then showed you how to set up a world.
Remember the water tools, no matter which one you're using, does require a landscape in order to work.
So make sure your worlds do contain that so that you can utilize those tools and your projects.
We then took a look at the ocean, lake and river tools individually and how, although they do widely different things,
their controls on them are actually very similar.
We then took a look at how we combined the river, lakes and ocean tools together in a single map to give us a landscape
that's got a lake with a river that goes into the ocean.
And then we finished with covering waves and buoyancy.
Remember waves can be stored to an asset to allow us to take this very complicated, but very powerful tool into an easy to use asset
that we can share between our rivers, lakes and oceans.
And then we also touched on buoyancy, which allows objects to float.
Remember, we can have objects also be pushed by the streams so that they can go into the lakes
and even into the oceans and in the oceans and lakes, they can bob up and down.
So that is going to do it for us for this video tutorial about quickly starting with the water tools.
My name is Sam Dider.
I'm a senior Unreal Engine instructor with Epic Games.
It was my pleasure having you and I'll see you next time.